what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with the hunt
for I guess really the search for Tony
Stark this is a big story this is
something like like a tissues long or
something like that and bidness doesn't
usually do stories that long those you
guys who don't know more often than not
in Marvel Comics most story arcs are
about six issues long for Iron Man this
comes after the events of secret Empire
now of course you could Empire as most
people know is one of my favorite
stories ever when it comes to the
character of Captain America well really
it actually goes as far back in civil
war 2 when Tony Stark was basically
killed by Carol Danvers essentially Tony
Stark you just kind of been in a
catatonic state he was just in a coma
and that was it and it was a way for
like Marvel and Bendis to basically put
him on the back burner and then on an
you know bring in riri Williams as a
character who I absolutely loved but the
fact remains here when it comes to Tony
Stark being in a catatonic state there
were a couple things that happen the
first was that ah you really saw it like
Amanda Armstrong picking up really
Amanda Armstrong and Mary Jane Watson
picking up at his place and we'll talk
about them here in a second and then you
picked up with Tony Stark basically
turning himself into an artificial
intelligence and then basically becoming
the trainer for Ruby Williams when she
became the new the new Iron Man more or
less but she was Iron Heart and so what
this does is this initially picks up
essentially at the stark Expo this whole
you know event that Tony Stark puts on
you know year after year in order to
bring together some of the greatest
minds now Amanda Armstrong is really the
one leading the charge on this whole
project since Tony Stark is gone now
Amanda Armstrong was introduced as part
of International Iron Man and that dealt
with the idea of Tony Stark tracking
down his actual biological parents
because that was a holdover from Karen
Gillan who had introduced the secret
origin of Tony Stark and revealed that
Howard and Maria were not actually his
biological parents and instead he was
adopted and so Ben is to kind of
continue that trend going forward in the
future of the Iron Man stories and so an
International Iron Man he tracked down
his actual mother who was basically a
rock star from like the 80s uh and then
we still don't know who his biological
father is or at least we know now that
the story's finished but at this point
in the story we don't know and so
basically a man was kind of going
through and saying hey look guys like
were put on this whole stark Expo
because it's what xx Stark would want
but from her perspective this is a
really crushing experience and the
reason why is because by and large she
never really got to know her son and
when it came to Tony Stark introducing
himself and meeting Amanda for the first
time it was hey come back over here to
Stark Industries basically become the
new CEO which is some
that he had implemented after he had
essentially died you know it was part of
his will his last will and testament but
she never really got to know her son now
her and Mary Jane Watson have really
been running the show ever since of
course Mary Jane Watson involvement came
by way of a combination of Dan Slott
spider-man and Brian Michael Bendis is
Iron Man but the idea here is that
between the two of them they're
basically fending off the Board of
Trustees if the board is trying to take
over control of Stark Industries since
Tony Stark isn't there he was really
like the one person keeping them at bay
and so because of the fact that Tony
Stark might as well be dead for all
intents and purposes
she ends up bringing in riri Williams
now at this point we transition to a guy
named Eric Lynch now Eric Lynch is one
of the higher ranking members of the
board but he's one of these guys has
really been kind of like pushing the way
for the Board of Trustees to be able to
take everything over and it's really
just kind of like lying in wait and
saying hey look there's only a matter of
time you know only a matter time before
you guys screw up what's been going on
really off panel and behind the scenes
here is that Eric Lynch and the board
have been exhausting every conceivable
legal option they have and essentially
what has come down to is that because
Tony Stark has been gone for so long and
because the the company really is
supposed to be owned by Tony Stark and
the person who owns it isn't there that
gives all authority to the Board of
Trustees this is essentially a hostile
takeover now at this point we transition
away from like riri and all that kind of
stuff and we focus on Doctor Doom this
is where things get a little crazy it's
because what you had is you had
invincible Iron Man and then you had
like the new Iron Man with Doctor Doom
and with infamous Iron Man this this
story arc that took place of Doctor Doom
because there were two distinctly
separate books when it got to the end of
International Iron Man and it got to the
conclusion basically going into like the
end of secret war I'm sorry the end of
secret Empire with Bendis is a
invincible Iron Man he combined the two
together and that's why you see two
distinctly different art styles because
as far as most everybody's been able to
guess they were supposed to be two
distinctly different books but with
Bendis basically getting out of Marvel
handing the reins over to whoever it is
it comes next
the result is that they were just kind
of crammed into a singular book but the
idea here is this is really more of like
businesses take almost on the events of
New Avengers it's kind of him a way for
him to sort of bring that back now for
those of you guys who don't know what
that means
back in the day with Avengers being one
of those titles that was ailing because
a lot of people think Avengers has
always been successful it's actually not
true throughout the 90s the only real
successful titles Marvel had were
spider-man and
various x-men related titles when the
Avengers title was canceled with
Avengers disassembled and then
relaunched as new Avengers the first
story arc was called the raft and it
dealt with the idea that the villain
electro had been contracted by Elektra
to essentially break all the prisoners
out of the raft and it was a way to kind
of bring the new Avengers team together
but this is very much a repeat of that
and the reason why is because it Rikers
Island a whole bunch of people have
escaped now this is really just kind of
repeat of that in a sense that you have
infamous Iron Man Doctor Doom who
basically responds and there's a handful
of people who have escaped now we'll
figure out who these guys are but of
course this also sort of ties into the
idea that Ben Grimm doesn't really trust
infamous Iron Man now one thing to bear
in mind here for those of you guys who
have been watching for a little while
this took place before the events of
Marvel two-in-one so that's one of the
reasons why you don't really see Ben
Grimm and Doctor Doom on good terms and
they even during true and one they
weren't really on good terms but this
takes place before that but switching
back over to back over to Amanda and
everybody what you end up finding out
here is basically the body of Tony Stark
has vanished the reason why this is so
significant is because of the fact that
with Tony Stark having been part of the
superhero community for a long time
having been director of shield being
really one of the founding members of
the Avengers having faced off and and
sided with the x-men he knows a lot I
mean he his hands are in everything and
so if somebody were to get their hands
on him and then simply like start
forcing him to divulge information they
could bring the entire security
infrastructure of the world crashing
down to say nothing of how easily they'd
be able to take out the various Avengers
now from here what we end up doing is
basically picking up with the arrival of
a guy by the name of hijack now when it
comes to David Bond the reason why they
call him hijack is because of the fact
that he literally hijacks vehicles like
you know technological stuff now he
originally made his appearance back in
2013 I'm pretty sure with uncanny x-men
vol 3 issue number 6 not gonna swear by
that but I'm pretty sure I'm right but
he was a Brian Michael Bendis creation
now anybody who's familiar with Bendis
will tell you more often than not he'll
use his own creations or he'll use
things that he's previously done to kind
of push along stories of these
committees writing at the time but
highjack showing up is really just like
he's he's basically a merc but he's here
because he was hired by the start board
of directors to essentially bring down
like riri williams and all that kind of
good stuff now this is one of the funny
things because the suit that RiRi has
was not Devon and not designed by Tony
Stark himself it was designed by her but
Tony Stark has been influencing her and
teaching her how to use these different
things but when it comes to this whole
thing in this situation popping off for
the most part
Hurd is sort of taking guidance from
Tony Stark kind of out flying these
various forces and and so on and so
forth and then eventually getting
outside the range of hijack to the point
that he can't really control these these
ships anymore and then ultimately she
ends up just kind of crash landing and
you know or she makes her escape anyway
and then ends up crash landing in around
neighborhood things like that of course
this also comes by way of Mary Jane
Watson macing David bond of macing
hijack in order to take his
concentration away but it's kind of a
cool little thing here that's one of the
cool things about Bendis writing is that
a lot of times he'll focus on smaller
characters who normally wouldn't really
have anything to contribute but then
gives them something as small as it is
and it just makes all the difference and
again it's just kind of a way to develop
characters but I thought your mains here
when it comes to uh really to dr. doom
Iron Man just kind of an aside not a
great big huge thing this will become
important later on but basically the
guys who bro who were who were broken
out of Riker's Island or essentially
like targeting really more it is kind of
like harassing and bothering him trying
to find a way to like defeat him and
kill him now these are small-time guys
living laser different things like that
nobody who is ever really significant
and so what we end up doing is picking
up of course when the Reaver williams
crashes back in her local neighborhood
and she's talking to Xavier and that's
one of the cool things I like about
revie's character for the most part I've
always loved her like I always thought
the development behind her was awesome
but she's also like this young girl and
when you're looking at someone like her
who is trying to step into the role of
becoming the new Iron Man it is kind of
funny because you have a tendency to
sort of forget she's a teenage girl
which means she goes through teenage
girl phases there's all those small
little things you know being nervous
around boys they know boys she likes
different things like that and it's kind
of a cool moment but once she gets
inside we basically end up finding out
that like her home is being rummaged
through by like essentially you know
groups that are I guess you know a
handful of people who were sent here by
stark stark you know Stark Enterprises
by the Board of Directors and they're
really pulling out all the stops now the
way that reira plays this is actually
pretty smart she basically says the
entire place is not really booby-trapped
but being monitored by like 17 separate
cameras and that is she you know if they
end up you know if they end up basically
saying hey look we're gonna continue
with this and like the whole thing will
be turned into a video and then it'll be
sent out there which is kind of a kind
of a significant moment and so what we
end up doing is actually transitioning
to Tony Stark proper now this is where
things get a little hairy Tony Stark
just kind of fell out of this birthing
container that's really what it was she
just kind of fell out of a container of
sorts and we have no idea where he is we
have no idea how he got there instead
he's met by the arrival of his mother
now
this really looks like a newborn Tony
stork that's really how this appears in
terms of the way he's drawn design all
that kind of good stuff but the idea
seems to be he's still in possession of
all of his memories up to the modern day
now is it a cheap way to bring Iron Man
back definitely but how do you really
bring Tony Stark back after he's
quote-unquote dead
you know after he's essentially dead but
it's kind of interesting because as he
goes through and starts talking to
really his mother they have this really
really touching tender moment here and
it's him basically saying like the one
thing that allowed me to hold on is that
it was basically you like what I've done
is I've essentially rebooted myself
mind body and soul I'm a recreated
version of myself when he's talking to
her he's kind of having this moment it's
like hey look I always wanted us to meet
I always wanted us to see each other and
then you have Mary Jane Watson who walks
in you know and Mary Jane Watson is like
well you know they're on their way
everybody's showing up here everyone's
been looking for you and then he's met
with a full contingent of the Avengers I
mean everyone you know like riri
Williams and and Moon Knight and like
storm and vision and all I kind of stuff
you know the x-men are there I mean it's
like the entire Marvel superhero
community because of the fact that he's
such an such a significant and important
member only for us to find out that
James Rhodes is also there and this is
when we start to realize the whole thing
is an illusion is basically a dream that
he's having and the reason why is
because James Rose is dead James Rose
died you know and really in the lead-up
to Civil War too and so it's kind of a
cool moment here it's actually kind of
kind of interesting because when you're
talking about this return of Tony Stark
it would have been a pretty easy
situation to just say and now he's not
done you know and it's like a to issue
story but a Seidman just kind of drag it
out and sort of you know invoke all this
character involvement is interesting
because then what we do is we basically
pick up with the arrival of Parker
Robbins now Parker Robbins was a
character created by Brian Kavon he
originally appeared in his own solo
series called the hood and he's one of
these interesting guys he's not really
on the level of Doctor Strange but he's
not a baseline human he can kind of
manipulate magic to a degree and he
basically fights demon energy or shoots
demon energies from his guns the
difference here with the hood is that
he's actually achieved a lot of pretty
significant things in terms of his
supervillain career I mean he was
inspired to become a supervillain that's
one of the reasons why he does what he
does but he's essentially really good at
forming what is for the most part like a
masters of evil those guys you don't
know back in the day the Masters of evil
if I remember correctly I want to say it
was a Roy Thomas creation but anyway it
was basically an alliance of the most
notable villains at the time there were
basically villains of the
the rosters sort of changed over the
years when it came to when it came to
the Masters of evil but with Parker
Robbins forming his own kind of army the
Ross were also changed as well but
that's why you see small-time guys like
living laser because the masses of evil
were people like like radiation man
Ulysses clocks small-time villains that
even at that point in time weren't super
relevant they weren't really all you
know that big of a deal but basically
Parker Robin shows up and like turns his
guns on dr. Jim uh and so it's really
kind of the way these things were
worried you know Bendis Lee doesn't like
a minor cliffhanger like a small little
cliffhanger and so what is up happening
here is Amanda starts to put two and two
together right their wife of two I'm
sorry the mother of Tony Stark starts to
put two and two together and she's
talking to like all the Avengers like
the Mighty Avengers in the in the whole
nine yards I mean it's like it's black
panther it is Luke Cage it's spider-man
I mean it's all these different
characters and the response is we have
no idea where Tony Sarg is no one can
find him this guy's off the radar now
this is kind of a cool thing and it's
actually it's actually important thing
to important thing to remember and the
reason why is because when it comes to
someone like Tony Stark where he was
director of shield while he wasn't
necessarily on the same level as like
Nick Fury
he still has a much higher level
intelligence but also access to
everything that was going on with
regards to to shield he did learn about
all these little nooks and crannies and
secret locations and places like that
here and there and that's the reason why
wherever Tony Stark is he's totally off
the reservation nobody can find him
because no one knows the different
places that he knows it's just things
that he was privy to as director of
shield or figured out along the way and
this is when a man that kind of starts
putting two and two together she's like
if Friday is the AI of Tony Stark that
he created before he died then she's a
program she does what she's programmed
to do and she's programmed to protect
Tony Stark and the response of Amanda
Armstrong is if she's programmed to
protect Tony Stark then why then she has
to know the location of Tony Stark and
then in the of course you know Friday's
response to this whole interrogation is
I don't I really don't know where he you
know I don't know where he is you know
the only way for me to know it'd be you
know to basically be in his head and
that's when she jumps into the basically
to the AI construct of Tony himself
that's been helping out riri Williams
this entire time and it's the coolest
thing because when she jumps in she
basically kind of switches bodies you
know kind of switches them back and
there's the really the question this
asked here is where is Tony Stark and
the AI contract does Tony Sidley
responds by saying well to be fair no
one ever asked me directly where he was
indicating this version of Tony knows
exactly
actual real-world Tony Stark is like and
it's kind of funny because it's like
well all they ever had to do is ask but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
four to the Rob core if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop on like
and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]